[Music]
setting a new world record of 2-22-43
joan benoit moves women's marathoning to
the next level
can anybody run at any age yes and
that's why i'm still running well into
my sixth decade
[Music]
this class is for runners aspiring
runners and for people who just have a
general interest in our sport i'm going
to talk about technique stretching and
strengthening exercises and the
importance of setting goals
running should be something that you
look forward to every day however many
times you're getting out there to run
the most important things are finding
the proper footwear making it fun making
it purposeful and making it something
that fits your lifestyle
one tip for new runners is to think
about your running in minutes as opposed
to distance and whether it's 15 minutes
a day or every other day the fact of the
matter is that you're doing it
there weren't many sports available to
young girls when i was growing up
because title ix legislation hadn't been
enacted into law eventually the past in
1972
and that's when i discovered that i had
a real passion for running
and i often asked myself if title nine
hadn't passed
what would i be doing today
it's up to you to discover how far the
journey of running is going to take you
and if you follow the lessons in my
class you will have running as part of
your life for a long long time
i'm joan benoit samuelson and this is
masterclass
[Music]
you